um how long have you been making music
man
I made my first song I was six I started
record around
um team and then I never dropped until I
was 17. how do you know
um
yeah yeah
that old all right he's hell yeah old
um no it's great so you you kind of
started taking it serious when you were
17. because that'd be the first time you
actually put some [__] out yeah yeah
that one I actually said I want to go on
here and push you through the world and
I stay consistent from from then on to
up into this point and now you got a top
100 record on Billboard
crazy crazy what was the thing that like
uh do you know kind of like what was the
moment or two that kind of really popped
This Record off where you kind of
noticed it to like really kind of like
take off yeah
it's very went crazy when I put it on
Tick Tock I put it on Tick Tock and it
went from
three thousand views to
to 10 000 version 10 to 50 to 102. you
know and it was it was just out it went
from Tick Tock to YouTube that's when it
got real you feel me I watched my
subscribers started going up but the
first time I seen it I made it home from
working at the um car shop I was working
at a car shop at the time
when I had posted a video I was going
through it like you know what I'm saying
so I had to end up taking that pain and
just putting into what I was going to do
like I took that and dropped that music
and now I took the pain from dropping
the music and put it in there pushing it
yeah without no money though so I had to
find a way without no money and for you
it was going to tick tock making like
content that no no the crazy part is if
I try everything like I did I build up
every platform like I did the Facebook
the Instagram the Twitter the audio mac
you know what I'm saying doing my main
three four and I had YouTube I'm working
on right but I never could get this junk
to go crazy you feel me
February 1st
just to um get the channel started I had
posted up I posted the old trailer and
the update of my haircut because I had
chopped it down
and then I was like I'm gonna let them
see the update and we'll bring back
the original video from like three or
four months so
I seen what they messed with it the new
haircut it went like 30 40
000.
I post new videos and waited like two
weeks later they approached their first
old video with the um live performance
and then the gym went from um
I made it home from working all day
because I did it randomly
stole it apart threw it on two charges
probably right Threw It on Tick Tock
kept going through the day made it home
at night and man lay down like well you
know your crazy the video your video got
like 250 thousand I'm like for real went
back to sleep you know what I'm saying
the reason I bet you see I went to sleep
right you know what I'm saying so boom
went to sleep
woke up it was like 1.2 1.3 million then
I was like this I was like this
this gotta be cheap this is crazy this
this ain't real you're right that's what
I'm thinking so I'm like nah let me make
sure it's real let me go get another
piece of the video and post it too you
feel me when I posted the videos in
between waited a couple days and I post
double
yeah
when I posted
it went from eight o'clock to 12 o'clock
it went July
2.3 million on tick tock on Tick Tock
Jesus from four hours
I gave it four hours just to see what it
would do right from eight to noon it
would hit 2.2 2.3 that's crazy yeah I
didn't even really I had to I'm looking
for who Wants in the car I need to get
somebody
right
[Music]
yo what were you doing at the car shop
like what was your job
my uncle got a car's job he'd be a
Motors so you were like a mechanic yeah
so what was CBS
and [__]
so you know your way around like an
engine
uh could you change your own oil I could
change my own oil I could change my own
oil I just ain't gonna work on nobody in
the car
just just you know chain my own oil and
brakes let's see you could do brakes and
oil it's eat yeah I don't do it for me
but if I'm doing some work
I got a little knowledge I'm curious
like working in a car shop in 2023 does
most of the business that comes in
people who had the catalytic converter
stolen and you have to put new ones in I
ain't doing none of that no I'm saying
because the catalytic converters just
get jacked everywhere so I'm assuming if
you're a car shop that's where they come
they gotta go get a new one that's what
I'm saying this shop all working there
they strictly focus on building Motors
like they they build Motors like they
literally they eat from scratch from
scratch it's just a block anybody here
they for now they don't know I'm trying
to building Motors they ain't touching
nothing they don't do no breaks no oil
none of that they ain't doing nothing
it's my uncle so he do Straight
personally he's building up crazy
engines crazy engine that they do street
racing down oh [__] so it's real like
that was the shot with that we had they
got the fancy car no no so what is the
fastest car down there
bundle baby remember we got bundo baby
what kind of car is that Malibu
about dick
don't don't tell you about that don't
they ain't gonna tell you what's under
that Hood At what point in time do you
quit the job with your uncle and you say
hey Uncle I gotta I gotta go oh oh I was
done I mean like like a week or two I
was still in the shop I'm looking at the
numbers going crazy still and you're
still working still showing up to work
getting your breath you're getting to
work you know what I'm saying geez I'm
really Jesus you know what I'm saying
still enjoying the moment of living
so therefore I just did what I did
and I was sitting in the car with this
guy right here I've been telling him
demo fantastic send me that video of the
bundo baby
he worked for my own he works longer
So eventually I mean obviously you got
chronic you gotta step away you gotta go
push the music right uh I'm gonna tell
you I would like [__] that [__]
I'm gonna just get on the music
understanding Mississippi work in the
shop I was like [__] I'm just get in the
music and let them work this [__] on do
what they do it you're gonna double up
have the job yeah and get them there I'm
gonna learn this [__] why why they do
this [__] and she got to a point where
I'm walking around that [__] and
everything I'm I'm coming in the shop
the numbers on the internet getting
crazy right you feel me so
they like one day it's like oh yeah he
cool
then you seeing they like oh [__] what's
up what's up bro yeah let me go from
what's up brother
Superstar you know what I mean so then
when everybody started noticing around
the shop now I'm like okay what you
doing here your record is crazy yeah
they like what you doing what you got
going you need to get up on it like that
so I sat in the um I pulled up one
morning set in the car I got now my boy
then we seen that we seen that child
BB now with the name BB we standing
cover BB on God Santa Claus sitting
there rolling up got down in the train
and Trans Am and God damn great car yeah
that [__] he's in right there oh
no yeah
everybody's hitting you up
here no you got to go right there so she
I mean he taught me to hit one of them
back I emailed one of them back and and
those [__] they're saying today they put
me on the plane that same day
I was in New York is how you ended up
doing the United Masters situation
no the on United Methodist is what you
came along with with
before that time they was in there
before that day because you already
getting distro through them yeah I'm
already my my already was through them
from like 2020 October right you know
what I'm saying so
I well now they were going crazy the
funny thing about it I was waiting on
United Master to hit me up because they
had the record you feel right right they
distributed yeah they distributed so I
was waiting on them to hit me up man
they were like they hit me up around
like a like a week a week before
a week before this this car you feel me
and I had talked to somebody but then I
was like I knew what I was gonna do
would do but still I'm like [__] I need
to go see what the options is right you
feel me so I ain't telling them there
where I went through all the ice and
worked out in my favor and then at the
end of the options
I seen all the moving around David and
then I ended up running into the Steve
stop and then
you got that we
we chopped and she ate dinner a couple
nights and [__] in the rooms [__]
I'm like I talked to the team and [__]
I'm like all right
if they in one thing if you showed again
they got confidence so [__] I say
until I find my team or if I'm gonna
rock with them I'm gonna see can they
you know what I'm saying
can they do this [__] for me you know
what I'm saying like what are we doing
like that like boom so [__] went on with
the move
I'm watching this [__] go crazy I'm
sleeping in every every car I'm going to
sleep in waking up new numbers waking
you up your [__] on the radio right that
Troy Marshall hits [__]
everywhere you go today
you're on the radio listen let's go to
sleep here it was so yeah well they
[__] in my sleep to my song you feel
me I'm like this [__] crazy bro you ran
down the road three four times before
you could do your destination
that's crazy I mean you look man that's
when you when you catch a record like
that I mean you're close to going number
one in urban so once let's go get to the
point where you're going in the cities
you're just gonna hear your record all
day
it's not a bad I mean you know
just think about from coming from a
mechanic shop a few months ago
it's kind of crazy uh what was your
childhood like like how did you grow up
like because obviously small area in
Mississippi where you're playing sports
where you like what were you into when
you were a kid man
I'm gonna be real man I want an
interesting name but the streets I'm
gonna be real
and then it got to the point where that
life got so bored
now it's so quick I mean before seven I
ain't seen so much
in the streets like before seven four
seven Jesus
before seven I probably seen more than
every 16 year old ever see right right
and got so tied up and
she monitored
and she really falling off you see what
I'm saying like I'm watching the game
like I ain't seen like she just fell in
love and watching it and watching this
[__] from the lifestyle they go from
Jordans every week to God damn you ain't
getting this [__] today you know from
you know what I'm saying go from sharing
me you know you go from eating in the
insurance and you know you know you
watching this [__] going down here to
eating out tonight getting sandwiches
and sardines and and noodles and got
them you know Hot Dog Smoke sauces and
ham and cheese and you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying you got
all kind of [__] they would you know
just at home like [__] kind of started
to go left in terms of the money yeah in
life it was oh you're watching this [__]
you're going from all this [__] eating
out and moving around here like I like I
say all that you're going from stuck in
the house can't move stuck in the
project you know what I'm saying you
can't move I'm stuck in the name of a
one way in one way out and then you you
gotta be in for the street lights and
you can't go outside the territory like
you know what I'm saying she just
apartment you can't go outside this
whatever you're gonna do all day from
then you can't stay in the house so you
gotta go hang out you gotta go outside
and you can't be around your porch right
you got to go everywhere out here but
around here where you at but when the
street lights come on you got to go home
when you see the first screen like you
gotta be home
you stay out past all them Street like
this you know hey are you gonna get
punished for that